Speaker 1: Let's hear from a few more
people. We do our calls via discord. You
can join the discord for free at David
Pakman dot com slash discord. Let's go.
Let's go next to Ben from
Texas. Ben, you're on the air.
Ben from Texas, you're on the air.
And Ben from Texas there, you're.
Speaker 3: Near me.
Speaker 1: Yet again.
Speaker 5: All right. Just to the callers there
asking what Joe Biden can do if we don't win the
midterms for abortion. I was thinking along the
lines, can Joe Biden do something to the effect of
withholding federal aid to
states that limit abortions past
three months or before three months?
Speaker 1: You know, that's a that's
a great question. It's an empirical question
that I just don't have the answer to in front
of me. Could he withhold federal. You're
just saying, like stop all federal aid to
states that ban abortion before three months?
Speaker 5: Well, not all federal aid. I mean,
it doesn't really affect the everyday lives of
people, but it can definitely hit the wallets of
the of the state that the state governments like.
Speaker 1: See, the thing about that is,
even if let's assume that he could do it, it
probably will hurt the people of the states
regardless. I think that that's a reality. I
don't know how you withhold money from states and
say we're going to withhold the money, but it's
not going to do anything bad to anybody. Well,
that seems unlikely.
Speaker 5:
Right. And then like I'm
from Texas, I'm where this
six month abortion ban has already taken place.
Speaker 1: I work six month,
a six week, six month or six.
Speaker 5: Week on a six week. I'm sorry. Got
it. I'm a social worker. I've seen the effects
that are draconian sexual education has had on
on people, you know, are like, you know,
our foster care is just in absolute
shambles. There's it's overwhelmed. Underfunded.
This is just it's insane to me that that we're
limiting women's access to health care right now.
Speaker 1: Do you think about leaving the state
of Texas over what's going on?
Speaker 5: Personally, I have
reasons that I cannot. But if I didn't have
those personal connections here in Texas,
I would definitely be looking to leave.
Speaker 1: Gotcha. Well, I mean, that's like most
people have connections where they live. That's
kind of the reality. That's why this whole if you
don't like it, just move, thing is is very absurd.
Speaker 5: Yeah. And then just one other thing,
just I don't know how much you all have talked
about it, but my Lord says that there's a
runoff election going on down here because our
congressman is Filemon Vela is taking an early
retirement to be a to be a lobbyist. Mm hmm. And
this is an area that's the district I live in,
South Texas, the Rio Grande Valley. This area
has been a strong blue for about 40 years.
And right now, it's looking like the
Republicans are going to be taking over
this this congressional district. Yeah. So,
I mean, if we if we can get the word out that
this. This cat might have flu. She is it she makes
she's she's another Lauren Boebert kind of deal.
Speaker 3: Oh, boy.
Speaker 1: I have
not been following that one. I have not been
following that one. But we will look into it.
Speaker 5: Yeah, she's she's
definitely a threat to look out for.
Speaker 1: All right. Ben from Texas,
thank you for the very informative call.
Speaker 5: Thanks, David.
Speaker 1: All right, Ben. On a slight
delay there with us. I don't know what was the
cause of that? I don't know the oranges of that.